[موسيقى]
على بعد 30 ميلاً من
العاصمة السلوفينية ، تبدو بحيرة جبال الألب هذه
وكأنها تنتمي إلى غلاف
كتاب قصص
[موسيقى]
مع قلعة خيالية على جانب منحدر
وبحيرة مياه عذبة خضراء الزمرد وإطلالات
على بعض أعلى قمم
جبال الألب جوليان  تجعل بحيرة بليد وكنيسة الجزيرة
مشهدًا مثاليًا لبطاقة بريدية
لزيارة كنيسة صعود ماري ،
يجب عليك ركوب قارب خشبي
معروف بالكثير الذي أخذناه
للزوار إلى الجزيرة في
وسط البحيرة لعدة قرون بمجرد
الوصول  الجزيرة هي عبارة عن 99 درجة حجرية
لتسلق للوصول إلى مدخل
الكنيسة ، ويقال أنه إذا تمكن العريس من
حمل عروسه إلى أعلى هذه
الدرجات وقرع جرس الأمنيات في الجزء العلوي ،
فسيكون الزواج سعيدًا
[موسيقى
] الكنيسة ستكون سعيدة  الأكثر شهرة لهذا الجرس
الذي تم صنعه في أوائل القرن السادس
عشر ويقال إنه هدية من أسطورة البابا ،
فقد كان هذا
الجرس الثاني للكنيسة الذي تم شراؤه
للكنيسة من قبل أرملة لا تطاق في
تكريمًا لزوجها الراحل الذي قُتل
ثم ألقي به في البحيرة عندما أحضرها الملاح
إلى الكنيسة
ضربت عاصفة غير متوقعة وغرقت الجرس
إلى القاع
، يُقال إذا استمعت عن كثب في
جوف الليل يمكنك سماع الغرق
يدق الجرس من أعماق هذه
النخبة الخلابة
[موسيقى].